a new medical study suggests that covid
could explain a sudden jump in cases of
pediatric hepatitis that severe liver
inflammation in children the world
health organization reported around 650
probable cases of pediatric hepatitis
last month and most of them the cause is
unknown the cdc is now investigating
more than 270 cases in this country
alone the new study from israel focuses
on just five children ranging from three
months to 13 years old but
if kovit could tell us how but it could
tell us how covet is affecting our kids
cbs news medical contributor that's dr
david agus joins us now with more on
this david when i heard it was just five
kids in the study can you really draw
conclusions from just five children no
no it's certainly not a definitive study
but it's a piece of data and now when
you know kids are suffering we're
looking for every piece of data we can
in these five children they looked in
their liver and they found no presence
of what we call adenovirus that was the
hypothesis going in that was a
particular type of adenovirus causing
this hepatitis but what they did find is
every child had had covet in the past
very common obviously to have covid but
we're starting to see that this may be
and they're actually calling it long
covered liver that it may be an effect
of covid on the liver and making them
more susceptible either to another
infection or this being covered directly
it's important that we think about this
and look into that data
so they only linked it because all five
kids had just happened to have had covet
is that is that the connection
yeah if you look at you know adults who
do have coping we've also seen in adults
that you can get some liver damage and
there certainly is the ace2 receptor
which is covalent vine all over the
liver and so the common thing and the
theme with all of them was they had a
prior covet
and there really wasn't anything else
they didn't find any other virus in the
liver when you look globally most of the
kids who've had this were not vaccinated
so 86 did not receive a vaccine and
there seems to be some correlation there
again this is early but we have to do
everything we can to protect these
children and certainly if vaccination
could prevent we should be doing it more
in children because we haven't been
doing it well here in the united states
so once you get it how do you treat it
so in this study they had kids who
presented very similar ways and when
they gave them steroids they got
dramatically better and again this isn't
really a study this is an observation
um but you know we have not
deployed steroids routinely and treating
it in the united states and it's
certainly something that will be put
into clinical trials now
most kids get better on their own with
this and a very small fraction will go
on to liver transplantation and a
remarkably few have died of this
horrible horrible situation
let's talk about the pfizer vaccine for
uh covet for kids under for what do they
say six months to under under five
between six months and five five years
old um it looks like that is going to be
approved very soon and if that happens
when could when could parents start
giving the vaccine to their children
yeah gail these are big steps you know
there's one cohort of kids in the
country one group of people that haven't
been able to be vaccinated and that's
the under five and so you're going to
see today and tomorrow the fda review
the moderna and the pfizer vaccine and
they could be available as early as next
tuesday for parents in this country and
it is an enormous step forward the
pfizer vaccine obviously been tried in
tens of millions of kids over the age of
five the modern vaccine and thousands of
kids under five and the hope is we will
have two vaccines to treat these kids to
prevent them from getting long covert or
serious complications of coven
yeah a lot of parents very excited about
this and other parents are like i'm not
so sure but for you you're saying look
if you can get it for your children
please do so
yeah it's not the fact that they're
going to be hospitalized or serious
illness which is very uncommon but it is
the long cova that i do worry about and
so if you can vaccinate your child there
really haven't been negative effects do
it do it do it
all right david
i am convinced i am a believer thank you
very much